Today, we'll talk about generalization and learning,
using the method of version spaces. The issue of generalization and learning,
is closely connected to the issue of incremental concept learning In both cases,
there are small sort of examples arriving one at a time. In incremental concept
learning, we made use of background knowledge, In generalization and learning,
background knowledge may not be available. Similarly, in incremental concept
learning, we control the order in which the examples arrived, but in general,
in generalization in learning, we may have no control over the ordering of
examples. Today, we'll start by defining version spaces,
we'll talk about version spaces that has an abstract technique.
Then we'll go into the algorithm for executing the technique of version spaces.
We'll also, towards the end, talk about an alternative method for
organizing the examples into a decision tree, or an identification tree.
This method is very similar to the method of incremental discrimination tree
learning that we learned when we were talking about case based reasoning